a vida ficou bom bem você
esse filme
acho borges
como bem você se conhece ficou
conhece-se corpo
e couro fui desconstrua sim escolher
desatento o fio
pressione
com bem vocês comigo
eu queria contar uma história sobre mim
mas eu não vou falar sobre mim sem falar
sobre você
sobre noite foi bem você se conhece
o senhor quer mais senhor senhora mas o
quanto mais adequado
é a água salgada do mar
é a água fresca do rio
é a água parada do lado mundo era água
nós somos água é filme se
transborde se
o isace se
10 construa se
com bem você se conhece
eu sou filha do mar
eu sou filha das água e eu vim pra manja
eu sou filha da azzaro e amanhã e eu vim
pra anja filha sophia filha das água
minha mãe e eu fico imã jean
sou filha do mar
ele é tratado
minha mãe é essa
meu fim
arranjar
desconstrua se questione se
diz construa
questione se 10 construa
desconstrua sim
a tata o senhor quer mais eu quero mais
senhora mas quanto mais
a fidel
obrigada